you know I did this segment a few weeks
ago about
liver King and Andrew tane and Jordan
Peterson and I didn't mean to say that
they are the same in their ideologies in
fact they are quite different but the
point was they end up pulling in
basically young men often with less
going on socially than they would like
often less relational you know less
involved in relationships than they
would like often without a defined or
successful career path yet and so they
end up being different flavors of
characters that pull in the same types
of people and I'll give you an example
I don't know anybody and I'm sure they
exist anecdotally but I don't know
anyone who works in you know has a good
job as a lawyer or as an accountant or
or you know even a success whatever and
is sitting there watching Andrew taint
videos you know what I mean